it's clear that a great many of us eat
too much and in response a huge industry
has grown up which advises us to consume
more quinoa pomegranate and fennel salad
and as often as we can kale an apple
soup but this is entirely to
misunderstand why we start eating
excessive amounts it has nothing to do
with food and therefore trying to change
our diet isn't the most logical place to
focus on efforts we eat too much because
what we're really hungry for isn't
available of course it looks as if
everything we could want should be to
hand our supermarkets and delis our
iconic
temples of consumer society our
restaurants spare no effort trying to
satisfy clips sir or madam be tempted by
Lobster Thermidor or a selection of
regional vegetables drizzled with olive
oil sauce from a tiny farm in the
Pyrenees it sounds nice but if we could
really choose anything wouldn't we want
a slightly different menu for example
unstressed conversation of father
marinated in mutual forgiveness
tenderized maternal love suitable for
those on a criticism free diet the right
friendship served on rye banter
accompanied by a side serving of
affectionate teasing fresh conversation
liberally sprinkled with poignant
anecdotes for to sexual appreciation
with all the trimmings our sommelier
recommends as the ideal accompaniment a
glass of full-bodied Chateau fantasy and
for dessert perhaps a generous scoop of
honeyed insight in other words it isn't
food we crave the menus of our actual
restaurants however chic prompt us only
in very limited and restricted
directions they understand and respond
to only a desperately narrow segment of
our true appetites
collectively we speak so much of food
and so little of what we properly need
it isn't Pizza Spanish cheese or
Argentinian State
we need friendship where we can confess
our darkest anxieties and be heard and
forgiven we need help in calming down at
key moments reassured that we can
withstand the very worst that may be
coming our way we are lonely and angry
within our own families and are crying
out for redemption and cathartic honesty
we need someone who can help us discover
our real talents in the workplace and
offer us a guide to realize our true
potential
we know that when reaching for a tube of
potato chips or biting into yet another
burrito that the problem doesn't lie
there we just don't know where else to
turn and there is at least a short-term
satisfaction to be found we eat too much
because we hate ourselves too much to do
ourselves the honor of looking after our
bodies our tragedy isn't our
unconstrained appetite but rather the
difficulty we have in getting access to
the emotional and psychological things
that would nourish our broken souls the
diet industry has latched on to the
symptoms of our unhappiness but not that
causes and therefore the solutions it
offers can only ever be temporary and
fragile it can't make us lastingly thin
because it's not engaging with what made
us manically fat a couple of hundred
years ago it was almost impossible for
most people to find anything very
pleasant to eat since then a vast
quantity of human ingenuity has been
devoted to enticing the palate we have
succeeded beyond our wildest
expectations but in so many other areas
we've hardly begun to supply ourselves
reliably with what we long to consume
which are to put it plainly
understanding tenderness forgiveness
reconciliation and closeness we eat too
much not because we are as we brutally
accuse ourselves of being greedy but
because we live in a world where the
shelves are still bare of the real
ingredients we crave
at the School of Life we believe in
developing emotional intelligence to
that end we've also created a whole
range of products to support that growth
find out more at the link on the screen
now